so derweil ist angela merkel weiter auf
großer abschiedstournee in glasgow hatte
sie zum beispiel gerade ihren letzten
richtigen auftritt als klimakanzlerin
klima war ja ihr thema also jetzt nicht
dass sie dafür bewegt hätten aber es hat
sich halt interessiert und diese woche
sind noch mal ordentlich prämienmeilen
bei der frau zusammen gekommen merkel in
rom dann glasgow und vorgestern ein ja
eher privater termin in frankreich
[Musik]
ja wir haben es gekürzt das ging auch
eine halbe stunde so weiter
fühle mich wie ein voyeur so aber zurück
zu den arbeits terminen der kanzlerin
der g 20 gipfel in rom sollte diese
woche den großen impuls bringen für den
anschließenden klimagipfel in glasgow
das hat so leider gar nicht geklappt die
g-20 ich zitiere mal bemühen sich um
null emission bis oder bis etwa zur
mitte des jahrhunderts steht da das
kannst du dich aus denken aber sie haben
münzen in den trevi brunnen gebaut
das muss dann auch mal reichen findet
ach ja und die kanzlerin hatte ihren
neuen azubi dabei haben sie das gesehen
den olaf ja ja man könnte auch sagen im
grunde ihren erben und das fand ich voll
niedlich weil der olaf durfte da in rom
schon mal ganz kurz reinschnuppern ins
kanzler nebenbei den großen darf kanzler
in spe olaf scholz noch nicht sitzen und
lauscht aus zweiter reihe
wie südens scholz am katzentisch ja
einmal hat er sogar was gesagt und zwar
darf ich noch ne cola ja
durfte nicht so und danach glasgow
klimagipfel in glasgow wo frau merkel
eben ihre letzte große klima rede
gehalten hat exakt drei minuten lang
dann hat man sich stellen sie sich das
vor von der bühne gegangen ganz recht
die erfinderin des klimaschutzes wurde
gnadenlos
ausgegangen dann werden wir wissen wie
wir am besten co2 freie mobilität co2
freie industrie und co2 freie prozesse
unseres lebens arrangieren können
deshalb in
der dekade des handelns in der dekade in
der wir jetzt leben
national ambitioniert das zu sein aber
drüber und nennt es ist nicht nur
steuergelder einsetzen sie redet einfach
weiter
der gong gilt für alle fräulein schön
aber haben sie zugehört angela merkel
fordert beim klimaschutz eine zitat
dekade des handelns jetzt wo sie aufhört
soll endlich gehandelt werden das macht
macht sogar total sinn wenn man darüber
nachdenkt nur zur erinnerung
nur zur erinnerung das
bundesverfassungsgericht hat neulich
erst ihr klimapaket total zerrissen okay
was man den rednern in glasgow insgesamt
lassen muss wenn die taten auch fehlen
die worte waren dramatisch genug jetzt
ist das eine minute vor zwölf auf der
untergangs uhr das ist eine bedrohung
für die menschheit wir haben nur noch
ein gefährlich kleines zeitfenster oder
wir akzeptieren dass wir gerade in
unserer eigene auslöschung investieren
wir graben sonst unser eigenes grab wir
stehen vor nichts kleineren als einer
tödlichen bedrohung
ja komm komm jetlag der arme oper beiden
zwei senatoren der demokraten haben
gerade seine klimapläne zerstört da ist
er vor schreck halt eingepennt selbst
wenn selbst wenn alle bisher zugesagten
maßnahmen überraschend umgesetzt würden
steuern wir wohl auf 2,7 grad
erderwärmung zu die welt steht am
abgrund das weiß übrigens auch die alte
dame aus london die sich noch persönlich
an die letzte eiszeit erinnern kann ja
natürlich
queen elizabeth höchstselbst hat in
einer video botschaft erklärt was in
glasgow auf dem spiel steht was immer
ich halte mal für sie mein handy mit
google übersetzer direkt daneben
heißt auf deutsch kriegt endlich den
arsch hoch ist und rettet ii verfickte
erde
ich wusste dass gar nicht dass die queen
so straße ist respekt aller respekt ja
leider hat keiner auf sie gehört china
verantwortlich für 31 prozent der
weltweiten co2 emissionen will erst 2060
klimaneutral sein in ihren laut
premierminister erst 2040 indien na gut
warte mal das ist
in 50 jahren ja wohl eher zu spät
deswegen planen pfiffige kommunen
bereits für den klima west case
karlsruhe zum beispiel bereitet sich auf
kommende fluten so vor ganz neu im
stadt- und wohngebiet sintflut ums
becken getarnt als spielplätze kurz vor
dem start gegen das maxim ist eine top
idee
warten die kinder toben auf der rutsche
wo ist das gerät so boris johnson dieser
personifizierte blondinenwitz hier hat
in glasgow was ganz wunderbares gesagt
er sagt die staatschefs seien beim
klimaschutz im grunde james bond der
eine bombe entschärft
ich freue mich gerade wie wäre denn wohl
ein bond film wenn bond wirklich so
handeln würde wie unsere staatenlenker
das spiel ist das bloß sie kommen zu
spät warnt wenn ich diesen knopf drücken
london von meinem leser zerstört ja aber
nicht wenn ich das verhindere so dass
mit blabla die dekade des handelns hat
begonnen wenn ich in wenigen sekunden
entschlossen einen abzug drücken starb
wäre ich damit eine katastrophe
biblischen ausmaßes
meine kinder und enkel wenn ich fragen
wo warst du james damals als blofeld
versucht hat london in die luft zu
springen da wirklich verdammt noch mal
sagen man wolle ich habe längst gedrückt
ich habe gehandelt als alle anderen
gelagert haben
das was wir heute erreicht werden das 15
uhr gast mit pro stunde zu haben wir
daran zusammenarbeiten dann können wir
das schaffen
das sind wir kommenden generationen
schuldig und dann kommen wir zu meiner
lieblings stellung kamasutra seite 400
sowas schreiben vor ekstase
[Musik]
eine bombe das bedeutet ich muss jetzt
sofort den roten oder weißen draht
durchtrennen also quasi unmittelbar weil
sonst
mitte des jahrhunderts im kino
vielleicht
[Musik]
so
aufnahme
hallo dies ist die automatische and cut
von oliver welke und der heute show
leider ist das video schon vorbei ihr
könnt den kanal allerdings gerne
abonnieren und ein weiteres video
anschauen vielen dank so müsse jetzt für
immer reich